[Music]
this video is for all board game geeks
and anyone who always has to win will
teach you some of the best tricks and
secrets that will make you win some of
the most popular board games out there
including Catan chess and battleship
stay tuned to learn how to become the
greatest Monopoly winner ever give this
video a thumbs up and hit that subscribe
button to never miss another video again
now let's check out 10 hidden secrets in
board games chess let's start with the
classic chess has been around for
centuries but the game still confuses a
lot of people we all know that one
person that always wins at chess and
here's how they do it the biggest secret
of playing chess is to make sure you use
your castles early protest players
always make sure they control the center
of the board
c4 d4 d5 and d5 are the most important
squares on the board and whoever manages
to control these squares usually
controls the entire game from start to
finish
chess also has pin fork and skewer
strategies that temporarily paralyze the
opponent's figure until you move your
own and eventually win the game Catan
Settlers of Catan is everyone's favorite
board game but not a lot of people know
how to develop strategies that will make
you win you should always be aware of
the resources you need to build your
developments and predict the possible
trade from the moment you put down your
second house one of the best hidden
secrets of Catan not a lot of beginners
get to take advantage of are the trading
courts which allow you to monopolize a
single resource and still be able to
trade and build new developments and
don't forget about the reward for the
longest road that can bring you to
victory points and totally change the
game result Scrabble there's always that
one family member that absolutely
destroys everyone else in Scrabble did
you know that this classic word game
actually comes with a lot of strategies
a New Zealander won a Scrabble
championship in a language he doesn't
even speak the key to winning Scrabble
is to practice extending your vocabulary
as much as possible pro players also
left to a dish at the end of their words
since they're all legitimate entries or
turn
words into adjectives and verbs whenever
possible there are also huge fans of the
word retsina
which comes with eight anagrams that are
all awesome point boosters you can also
pay close attention to hooks which allow
you to add a single letter to the word
but significantly boost your points
ticket to ride Ticket to Ride is a
popular railway theme Ford game its goal
is to connect as many cities by building
roads the game has a couple of secrets
and strategies that allow you to always
win to win Ticket to Ride
you should always identify route
segments that will make your overall
route shorter you should also draw
wildcards from the face down deck to get
to cards instead of one if you're
playing the USA version you should also
secure 3 choke points as quickly as
possible because they allow you to
advance much faster they are the Los
Angeles to Phoenix Nashville to Atlanta
and Houston to New Orleans with those
you'll win every single time battleship
battleship is one of the most classic
board games ever that's been first
played on pencil and paper
since then the game has developed into
one of the most popular board games ever
here's how you can develop a strategy
that will make you win battleship every
single time the best battleship tip is
to use a density function and take into
consideration different ways the ships
are built and how many squares they are
taking you can also imagine the board
looks like a colored checkerboard and go
by the principle of sinking every other
Square combined with the density
strategy will significantly reduce the
number of moves needed to sink the ships
taboo we love word play games and we
can't possibly forget about this classic
that's definitely a family favorite and
this is how the most competitive people
always manage to win taboo keep your
eyes and ears open on potential
penalties from your opponents as they
bring your own team points you should
also play taboo with people you know the
best and take advantage of inside jokes
and what you know about the person you
should also focus on thinking about
meanings of a single word to help your
teammate figure it out faster instead of
trying to explain something they might
not understand so are you ready to get
competitive with taboo risk risk is one
of the best and most intense strategy
games out there that involves plenty of
clever thinking in order to win risk you
have to rely on more than just luck you
can focus on weighing the odds of your
dice landing on a certain number if
you've played Catan before you know that
this makes it possible to determine how
the game will play out from the start
another sneaky move is to attack your
opponents as they attack each other and
lose their troops you should also take
advantage of the diplomatic side of the
game and figure out which players the
best to ally with and how to make the
betrayal less severe in order to win
code names
although code names is a fairly new game
it's proven to be a pretty popular
family gathering activity the rules of
code names are simple the players have
to guess their team's words before their
opponents guess theirs
here's how you can win code names and
make the game even more entertaining for
everyone else make sure you have someone
comfortable with words doing the calling
and turn their back after they've read
off the clue don't focus just on the
clue you get for the card try to
encourage linking more words together
with the clue you should also make sure
they touch the card as well as say the
code name and lastly if someone's taking
too long
threaten to use the timer to spice
things up forbidden island moving around
a mysterious island requires a lot of
strategies if you want to win forbidden
island is a popular game with plenty of
Secrets to win you should always save as
many tiles as possible including the non
treasure and non Launchpad tiles
you should also reevaluate your strategy
if the number of the game players
changes and avoid having fools landing
or a treasure tile down don't forget to
use your special abilities at some point
during the game if you think Forbidden
Island is easy you should test your
teamwork skills with the legendary map
which can be challenging with even some
of the most advanced players
manopoly are you ready to hear some
monopoly tips from the ultimate monopoly
champion who even managed to beat her
husband on the way to the finals this
pro player states that you should never
buy hotels instead focus on four homes
to have a lower rent and stop people
from building their own you should also
avoid buying utilities and focus on
railway stations instead but the best
strategy is to assess which is the best
performing property early in the game
depending on whether you need to build
houses or hotels monopolies can be
frustrating but we're sure we're not the
only ones with the tips on how to win
share your tips in the comments below
and that's it for our video for more
videos like this check out 20 toys no
kid wants to receive on their birthday
[Music]